President Trump will not turn over
documents House Democrats they want
supporting placement of a citizenship
question on next year's census the
president's assertion of executive
privilege comes as his eldest son makes
a return visit to a key Senate committee
chief intelligence correspondent
Catherine Herridge has specifics tonight
from Capitol Hill on this vote we have
24 yeas and 15 knows the House Oversight
Committee voted to send a contempt
resolution for Attorney General William
Bar and Secretary of Commerce Wilbur
Ross to the full house after the
administration asserted executive
privilege over census records this begs
the question what is being hidden when
we rush to hold people in contempt it
has a chilling effect on anybody wanting
to go the extra mile the administration
argues the census question was added to
improve compliance with the Voting
Rights Act but Democrats are demanding
to review internal deliberations
alleging the census question may
discourage minority participation in
turn impacting congressional races as
well as federal money one Democrat cited
her immigrant mother now a US citizen
when they asked her about that in her
question it's gonna make her hesitate
even though she's been in this country
for four decades we all know that's
exactly their true intent here
Republicans accused their colleagues of
overreach Democrats know the Supreme
Court will rule by the end of this month
on the citizenship question but they
hope to use this committee's oversight
power to create a controversy around
this issue try to impact the court's
decision during an oval office meeting
the president called out Democrats over
their demands for census and Russia
records we gave them everything we were
the most transparent presidency in
history so now the Democrats want to try
and win an election and I think the
American public is not going to stand
for
behind closed doors Donald Trump jr.
fielded questions from Senate
investigators over apparent conflicts
between his earlier testimony and that
of Michael Cohen the president's former
personal attorney who played guilty to
lying in financial crimes at issue
apparent discrepancies over the 2016
Moscow real estate project that never
materialized and the June 2016 Trump
Tower meeting where Russian lawyer
promised dirt on Hillary Clinton I don't
think I changed anything of what I said
because there was nothing to change I'm
glad that this is finally over we were
able to put some final clarity on that
late today the offices for attorney
general bar and secretary Ross issued
statements on the house contempt vote
calling it quote shameless and quote
undermines Congress's credibility with
the American people separately the House
Judiciary Committee confirmed that
former White House communications
director hope Hicks will submit to a
transcribed interview next week hopes is
currently the executive vice president
and chief communications officer for the
Fox Corporation Bret captain Harris loud
on the hill Kevin thank you